you know
hello folks welcome to rational science
hopefully we have a good day today
okay so let's get started we're going to
be answering maybe some questions at the
end of the show uh so uh have your
important questions ready if they're not
important we will not touch them okay
um and we try to get as many as we can
here uh anyways we're going to start as
always uh with our Extinction segment
okay before even that this week I had a
little glitch as a lot of you know
and uh this is what happened
um YouTube gave me this warning okay
and it gave me that warning in my two
channels and where I uploaded the same
video one channel was just a warning the
other channel uh was um
you know it was uh it's like if I got a
strike because uh it was uh blocked for
like four days
and I worked with the people at YouTube
and they said it was a glitch and I do
believe them I think they were working
to try to fix it I mean these are just
workers they don't care and I think
they're workers from YouTube I don't
know if they're from the community that
just you know volunteered to help I
don't know if that's the case I don't
know who these I mean like Wikipedia or
well I don't I don't yeah something like
that like there's a community of people
out there that help out and counsel
people and tell them about the rules and
all that kind of stuff so I don't know
if it's that or people who are paid by
YouTube you know who come in there and
really actually try to fix the problem
if they can't handle it then they you
know uh I guess uh take give it to the
technicians or whoever anyway and some
of those people you know unfortunately
um they're from Philippines or India as
you probably know and they speak all
this up pigeon in English it's not very
good uh you know the companies to save
money uh they go outside the country in
a sub contract and maybe it's not good
for these companies you know I and I
guess they're going to be moving into
chat bgt you know uh in the future yeah
chatpt GPT I don't know what it stands
for I know that but the you know because
they're gonna have uh the Bots answer
you and pick your problems and if they
can't fix it I guess they go to like
layers of yeah help they have all these
layers I mean they already have that
over the phone so what was the issue
about uh well I uploaded a video that
had to do with this fellow okay he's a
nasty guy he's been going around causing
some trouble for people can't even
mention his name okay he's a nasty guy
you can look them up and what it was is
a video that dealt with him okay and uh
it was an international conference
conference not in Cuba or in North Korea
it was a conference in Brussels that's a
country in Europe is it like Harry
Potter or Voldemort He Who Shall Not Be
Named more or less like that uh yeah it
was a European conference on this
subject and there was a doctor who just
spoke his mind but apparently his name
is a bad word you won't see him around I
couldn't find him on the internet I can
only find people who speak of him so
he's utterly censored and in fact that
he started his video by saying something
like this has ruined my life
so uh yeah I can understand him but when
I looked around I found uh Mr Kennedy
you know Bobby Kennedy's son you know uh
and uh he's been banned since uh 2021
for talking about kovic and it turns out
that the now they're going to allow him
to come back in there he says he's still
uh you know as far as this uh
news came out uh he was not yet uh
officially allowed to come back into
Instagram but he was um blocked for two
years and now it says there as he is now
an active candidate for president of the
United States we have restored access to
Robert F Kennedy Junior's Instagram
account now how's that so if if you say
something nasty and they cancel your
account no problem just run for
president and they'll restore your
account now how's that for a deal okay
so they restored his account only
because he's running for president
you don't have to win you just have to
run huh you don't have to win no no you
don't have to win I I don't he may not
even win but I mean all you have to do
is run just apply and say you're a
candidate everyone who has their
Instagram accounts banned just right for
president and you'll be okay and he
wasn't the only one you can see that the
censorship is uh quite widespread here's
a lady
a Ukrainian lady here in Germany okay
and she spoke not against the disease he
spoke against uh the war in Ukraine okay
he says Germany finds a woman 900 euros
for saying Russian invasion of Ukraine
was necessary and I guess he takes the
sides of uh other Russians and I guess
the Germans didn't like that very much
and so they find her maybe even put her
in jail or executed I don't know what
they're gonna do but yeah there's a lot
of censorship out there for different
things in all these lands of freedom
so the way I look at it all these people
are no different really than uh North
Korea or Cuba and any of those places
they're all the same they all censor the
key information I mean if you if you go
out there and speak you know to the
ocean
they don't care you know they don't you
can you have freedom of speech
but don't uh don't speak into a
microphone that people can hear okay
that's the issue don't speak your mind
okay uh and here's another issue that
came up remember fingernails the guy who
made a uh a couple a couple of videos on
uh criticizing my theories and my uh
approach to science
and uh well uh you can see that he had
painted fingernails so I call them
fingernails because I thought that was
kind of weird in a guy okay but someone
uh pointed out that uh this one has gone
beyond the Call of Duty
and uh he's transitioning he wants to
become a woman okay so he's explaining
that in a video if you want to see it
over there anyways uh he's uh
transitioning means he's trying to
become a woman he's essentially come out
of the closet okay
um a lot of people doing that these days
or at least it's heavily in the news
okay so what do you think of that okay
I don't know uh we live in
strange times or we can say uh what is
it queer times it doesn't even phase me
anymore yeah yeah there's so much news
it's it's unbelievable
okay uh
I say that this has to do with this uh
loss of genetic diversity over centuries
okay I think a species can only lose
genetic diversity it gains it at the
beginning then it starts losing it and
even though we have mutations constant
mutations in the population it's the um
you know the uh Founders effects the
population bottlenecks that overrule
that right you made a great jump there
why are we talking about this all is
that well because I'm saying that this
well that's the Preamble now I'm going
to tell you why why I'm mentioning that
I'm saying genetic diversity in fact
that we lost our genetic diversity is
the cause is the cause of why um why we
have these situations today of people
transitioning and coming out of the
closet and so on okay so that's what
it's got to do with and here we have um
an example of that uh Mr Calhoun he
reproduced or he produced homosexual
reality in the lab okay and here are his
mice famous experiment there's the
utopian Universe number 25 he did many
of those over a 30-year period okay he
started in 1947 1948 and ended up in
like I think 1975. so he he was doing
all these experiments first with rats
then with mice uh almost every year
every two years okay and so what
happened well here you can see the chart
okay
let me remove this one here
you can see the chart and you can see
what's happening to the population of
mice he started out with the
grandfathers you know the the seed yay
and uh there were four pairs of mice uh
they had you know there were normal mice
in the sense that they immediately the
males got a hold of the females they
made their nest and they started
procreating normal stuff right but then
after 2 200 mice uh protected against
all disease
um they had all the food and water they
wanted they held the nesting material
they wanted the only issue was space
okay and and the fact that they all
descended from the same grandparents
that's an important one also and you
have to remember also that
um
you know these mice were not field mice
they were mice that they got from a
laboratory which already had their jeans
you know washed out over the centuries
and this is this was their starting seed
and you can see what's happening there
the uh mice multiply and then they go
into Extinction but before they get to
Extinction a lot of them become what
autistic and homosexual so something
affected their brains to the point that
Mr Calhoun said they are no longer mice
and he said he was a psychologist uh so
he was looking at it from a mental point
of view and he said that humans are
following the same footsteps and Mr
Calhoun died but I think he would have
seen that what he said is quite true it
happened you know that's what we're
seeing it has to do with genetic
diversity though I think it's got a lot
to do with it because of this look let
me give you another example that's a
place where we disagree a lot yeah I
know we we disagree on that but this is
the issue this is the way I look at it I
was nine years old and I fell in love
with a girl next door okay nine years
old damn
and she was six years old and I wasn't
the only guy I had my next door neighbor
and uh another guy down the street uh
the next door neighbor is nine just like
me and the other guy was only seven all
three of us were Head Over Heels over
this girl okay she was just a knockout
she was a beautiful she was a doll okay
and you know it wasn't like my father
and my mother said hey Bill you got to
look at girls not at boys you know that
never happened you know it's like nature
called
okay and when I was around 11 I fell in
love with my English teacher he was she
was my uh Homebrew teacher and um
and uh you know so these are these are
things that are in nature you're born
with it no one teaches you these things
you have the Call of the Wild to sort of
speak and so you know isn't that jeans
uh isn't that you isn't that nature I
mean that's the way I look at it
primarily I think in other words if if I
had to judge this guy which I don't I
mean it's his problem but I mean uh I
think he was born that way okay he
already it's not that he was educated by
his parents to be that way or by school
system or by peer pressure
he's already been born that way yeah he
can't do anything about it that's the
way I look at it okay and I think it's
got to do with the fact that humans have
washed their uh jeans their pool you
know their genetic pool over the
centuries it happens to all species I
think and with different results not all
of them become homosexual and autistic
but uh there you see uh the experiment
by Mr Calhoun with mice and it does
happen uh I've also read about there's
quite a bit of material uh about sheep
uh ten percent of the sheep are
homosexual okay and then you can look
that up and lions you know you'll see
lion mountain lion hopefully they
weren't taught that in school
well I since I think it has to do with
the density right okay one question I
would have is
um there's that
phenomena where animals who end up on an
island end up shrinking yeah uh insular
dwarfism correct
but since they're on an island don't
they have the same circumstances as the
Calhoun mice well couldn't we test it in
those in those situations what you'll
notice is that the density is very low
so there's insular dwarfism but is it to
some degree by the food chain bro
there's a density dependent birth rate
and it has to do with crowdedness you
know so the fact that we humans are
crowding into cities that has that's
very likely
specifically the insular dwarfism yeah
when and when a species ends up isolated
on an island yeah do they not experience
the same Calhoun mice fate because of
other circumstances because isn't that
essentially the same yeah but then which
I think what you had when they all
turned gay what you what you have to
look at there is that animal that
species where is it in its history in
its development because well no no
that's not you're talking about I'm
asking like did that happen
I'm not saying well I'm not sure anybody
and see when they investigate insular
dwarfism what they see as smaller
elephants for example right that's
happened and uh and maybe that happened
also to the uh florences you know
implorences man which they found over
there in the Philippines in an island
they become they're small and so one of
the theories that maybe IBS or dwarfism
affected them but the issue here is in
uh all these cases nobody really
investigated if there was any
homosexuality among the elephants or
ammonia florensis that's one issue the
other issue is that uh when they got
there there were relatively few of these
animals a few elephants few florences
okay they only found I think six of them
or eight something like that
um so you know there's been no real
study because it's not like a widespread
phenomenon okay uh that's one issue the
other one is the one I raise is that
over the centuries you know you lose 10
genetic diversity but not all species
lose that genetic diversity at the same
Pace we come from the same stock maybe
as the temps okay we if somewhere we in
in the past we meet okay we had a uh one
grandfather grandmother somewhere out
there you know and uh you know in The
Chimps today have more genetic diversity
uh among 100 chimps in a troop than the
entire human race
and part of the reason I think is they
don't have density uh at this point you
know they have all the space they want
that's one issue but the other one is
that you know maybe you got to look at
it in their evolution you know where
they are where their genetic diversity
uh stands in their history and you know
they're more primitive maybe and we're
much more advanced that's why we've got
all our genes washed up but yeah anyone
who you marry today is your brother or
your sister from a genetic point of view
that's my
Theory okay okay let's move on here we
have uh this which came out in the news
this week uh scientists discover a
virgin birth in a crocodile now this
happens in other animals that I've heard
about and there you see it baby croc was
a parthenogen the product of a virgin
birth okay so
um yeah this Croc did it all by herself
okay and uh there you see at the bottom
it explains how that happens here's how
a virgin birth happens there's an egg
cell matures in a Mother's body it
divides repeatedly to generate a final
product with exactly half the genes
needed for an individual three smaller
cellular sacs containing chromosomes
known as polar bodies are formed as
byproducts polar bodies usually wither
away but it vertebrates that can perform
parthenogenesis one polar body sometimes
fuses with the egg creating a cell with
a necessary complement of chromosomes to
form an individual so some animals have
the ability
to produce you know children without the
male okay in others a female does it all
by herself and it happened to us also I
think with Mary and the Archangel he
came through a window a bearded guy or
and then left for us through the same
window when her husband appeared you
know so uh yeah we have virgin births as
well in humanity I guess right
happened once yeah
that's what the women tell their
husbands why this guy come black if
you're away well you know virgin birth
okay
okay and then other great news involving
um
Extinction here we have people who are
searching the skies for um
extraterrestrial intelligence sometimes
I think they should Point their
telescopes to seti or to you know search
for extra
intelligence or to Cambridge University
if I know if there's any intelligence
there still on the crocodile right ah
you're still on the crowd okay yeah any
crocodiles are really old species yes or
no where are they in their evolution but
I thought like according to biologists
and anthropology that they're one of the
oldest thing then the sharks
uh sharks and Crocs are not old no let's
put that on the table because people
people make a lot of mistakes there and
and they just take bits and pieces and
they say oh you have uh the lungfish
today and they say oh that dates all the
way to I don't know devonian or whatever
not true the animals over there is like
ananderthal to us I'm sure that a
lungfish today saw one of those lungfish
on those days you'd run the other
direction especially if you meet them in
a dark alley but then isn't it so the
Sharks the Sharks and the Crocs have not
been around for Century for since the
Cretaceous but okay we had different
species they all look the same you know
but it but if I take a if I take a a
shark today or a Croc today and I
compare it against a shark or a Croc of
the days right after the Cretaceous uh
collapse you know Cretaceous uh tertiary
Extinction there
uh 65 million years ago they're not even
similar they're two different animals
they have two different species that's
what I mean you know they're right they
could they wouldn't be able to have
babies together but are there jeans also
washed up because they might have birth
defects across the two heads and
well uh I don't know about Crocs with
two heads that that might even happen
they'll put it uh you know past them but
there's uh animals that had uh two heads
uh among them humans you know Human
animals we have more washed up is what
you're saying yeah the reason that
happens but you always use it in a
retrospect you always use it as like a
ad hoc like oh if anyone has a birth
defect their jeans must be washed up
good that's right but you don't do it
but there's no way of you're kind of
just using it as a as a Band-Aid well
what I'm saying is at least we got to
look at that uh there's I think genes
have something to do with it that's my
main point uh and I've talked about
peaches you know the peaches a couple
thousand years ago they were like
berries and we selectively bred them you
know over the centuries and we always
pick the big ones and today you have a
peach that's this big you know and
that's not the peach that was there two
thousand years ago and I planted a peach
tree you know in my garden
and there were five instances five
peaches that came out of that peach tree
that were uh siamese twins two-headed
peaches and I'm saying that it's got
something to do with the fact that that
uh peach tree you know has suffered an
evolution to the point that today they
have their genes washed up and so yeah
now we're having two-headed uh peaches
and it's not the only veggie or the only
fruit out there that has you know
two-headed things so I think it's got
something to do with with genetics you
know I don't think uh they went to
school and say I'm gonna have two heads
this is something that has to do with
genes that's the way I look at it
primarily okay okay let me get on to
seti here and they said they saw they
said uh seti is a search for
extraterrestrial intelligence I think
they're in California yeah yeah yeah
they have all these uh listening posts
you know they want to listen to
um what is it to
um signals coming from outside yeah or
whatever whatever they can hear you know
maybe maybe they get some electronic
waves electromagnetic waves well that's
what they say yeah we're not going to
see them the first thing we'll probably
see is their radio waves was that yeah
and uh some people say no bill they are
here
oh okay so here we have uh the uh news
uh the you know the uh is it the
headline repeated signals from the
center of the Milky Way could be aliens
saying hello new study uh claims right
and so they go through this and the
question is whether this has anything to
do with science or reality okay whether
there's anything out there that has
contacted us and one fellow says hey uh
they have they're already here okay
and I think they're all in Cambridge
University okay but that's this fellow
here okay and he says that uh his name
is David brush and he says that uh he's
convinced he knows he's got the inside
scoop that the aliens have come to Earth
and it's just being hidden from you
because the government you know is
trying to uh prevent you from knowing
this information you might Panic that's
that's the rationale behind it or maybe
it's got to do with national insecurity
and that's why they're withholding this
information right so here's the uh
here's the news says uh David's uh grush
he worked as an unidentified aerial
phenomena task force with top clearance
levels so they're saying he's not just a
nobody he's a guy who's worked out there
in in the you know he had the inside
scoob he worked inside the government
what do you work on extraterrestrial
stuff so that doesn't strike me as
strange you know he works in this and
then he comes without saying oh yes we
know they're there and he says it's kept
hidden from the American people uh-huh
and what is he kept hidden well he says
uh exotic origin of non-human
intelligence
okay so he's saying that all this stuff
he says they recovered an intact and
partially intact vehicles of non-human
origin
and so the first question we have to
think ask is whether this is another
move by the U.S government to
um like Assange and Snowden to fool
people into believing that you know that
um these people are real that's the
first thing we gotta ask yeah we have to
ask that's the first thing I got like
five questions before that no no that's
the person because that's the first
thing you think of okay the government
is is
trying to convince people of of BS
essentially well because uh this guy
comes from the government that's the
first one he comes out he's allowed to
put uh what is it uh classified
information in the public domain
and and the government doesn't execute
them or torture him or anything that's
weird I mean the first thing the US
government would do is stop this guy
from I mean he's still in the U.S it's
not like he ran like Snowden first of
China and then to Russia or uh what's
his name um tell me what you said
because I got a counter already okay go
um I'm the U.S government right you are
and where you are you were born in
Austin let's even assume what are we
assuming
that that they know that there are that
like
if you have a guy saying that there's
aliens
if you shut him up after he already said
it it would give weight to what he's
saying wrong no you don't let him talk
well you don't wait till he goes out
there you make it sound like they have
that much control they do what oh yes
they do oh I mean if he goes to a
newspaper okay who runs the newspapers
well we know who owns all the newspapers
in the United States right so you go
over there and you say hey I want to
print this I just took it out of the
government it's classified information I
want you to print it oh yeah oh yeah it
depends on where your friend it is oh
Washington Post maybe New York Times I
don't know you know uh one of those
unknown places you know yeah they're
going to stop you immediately and in
fact they're gonna call the US
government and usually go through
Assange or through Snowden they'll call
the US government and say Hey you know
there's this buddy who's trying to get
in touch and they just ask why does the
government care about telling us that
there are aliens good question why why
did they why did they uh throw uh gas in
the fire
uh with flat earthers I mean Flat Earth
is also a U.S government run operation
that has expanded why who would believe
in the Flat Earth today I mean something
yeah yeah you see that really losing me
what you're on Earth is a government
I thought we were the rational ones but
listen there's a group of people and
they say flattered okay great now
suddenly more people start believing
that and that's when you know they're
infiltrated but they're all all these
organizations when they start growing
they're always always 150 always
infiltrated the Ku Klux Klan uh you name
it uh Planet I can understand killing
people no they cares about Flat Earth
because they need to steer it's steering
when you see that I mean you mean give
me it from the from the government's
perspective when you have thousand and
then hundreds of thousands then millions
of people believing in something yeah
the US government wants to get in there
to steer that in the direction that they
wish it to be steered
[Laughter]
they steer they steer they just they
they don't yeah okay
they just steer people and they say okay
there's a million people who are
flatterers
saying so you're saying you have a lot
of people that believe one thing so it's
essentially like a cult yeah and since
it's a cult they can be you can say
organized now you think they can be they
not they can manipulate not just
manipulated but you're saying they can
be manipulated as a group to do other
things that have nothing to do with
flatter is that what you're saying you
don't think religion yeah I'm talking
about you know some of these people who
go out there like this fellow who died
the other day uh forgot his name now
um and they have all these religions and
there's millions of people who pay
attention to these religions you don't
think they're infiltrated
well yeah but so like well what I'm
saying is you have listening that's one
issue you know they need to listen
what's going on in there that's one
issue they may not have to do anything
they just send someone in there and
listen and then if they need to steer
that they will work from the inside if
it's an important organization they will
try to steer it somehow I doubt the the
human governments are that organized the
U.S government spends 92 billion dollars
on intelligence and you would say well
you know we have the Russians and the
Chinese now that's 10 cents the the
infiltration is to steer the U.S people
the American people not it's not I mean
Assange at Snowden are there to steer
the American people they're not there to
fight against Russia or China and that I
can understand you know why did China
get rid of uh Snowden says get out of
here he was there three days and they
said well you got 72 hours to get out of
here yeah and he went to Russia and why
did Russia accept him because he's not
spying against Russia he's spying
against the American people he's the
leader of the contras of the United
States that's Wikileaks and spy
yeah but but no but it's steering but
because see these people are there now
and now they can Orient you and say that
yeah but
Flat Earth is is a similar thing it's a
similar notion imagine you have
thousands and hundred thousands in a
million people you say well look there's
a growing movement okay Grassroots
movement yeah and we want to take it in
the right direction Diana NAACP another
organization will take it in the right
direction
you know maybe they need to steer maybe
they know maybe it steers all by itself
they need a listening Post in there how
do they catch drug traffickers always
always they send someone inside
oh
okay yeah
how many lists yeah the list ends before
flat earthers and Aliens you think
they're going out
having a dude like hiring a guy to
spread false information about aliens
you think like okay I know that they're
wasting a lot of money but Jesus Christ
that's a lot of taxpayers money talk
well I mean depends on what they need
for you to believe at some point they
need maybe for you to believe in flying
saucers another time they need for you
to believe in the Flat Earth you know so
they it depends on what what how they
want to steer you okay so they put out
what fake news or you know or Orient the
organization from the inside I highly
doubt they think that they can steer
uh
non-cut sorry people who are who are I
want to say not Beyond The Pale but like
conspiracy theorists yeah can you really
steer them much they're like yeah those
are I mean a lot of people who were 9 11
deny you know the they did believe the
official story from 9 11. yeah and then
they follow Snowden and they follow
Assange and so so the uh the US
government says uh we didn't get you
there we got you now we got you anyways
but aliens though that's where it's like
jeez well tomorrow they might need the
information they might they might say
you know there's a war in Ukraine and
maybe Ukraine loses hey look at the
flying saucers we have this this uh
these extraterrestrials come in so
people forget about Ukraine start
thinking about that I mean it's the way
you manipulate the the information
anyways uh here's why we are not we
don't have extraterrestrials here like
this the fellow grunge uh says okay
here's the uh linear regime according to
uh the uh rope hypothesis and any
vehicle trying to leave the bird speak
and here you'll see it from the start
hold on
there's the bird speak from our sun okay
and if you try to uh leave the bird
speak you know that uh
have all the ropes that are connecting
every atom of the earth to every atom of
uh Alpha Centauri for example right if
you try to leave that birth beak you
enter a linear regime where gravity is
not the same doesn't work the same way
as it does here on Earth okay and all
you'll see for eons is uh you know just
uh going right through the ropes you're
just sliding through the ropes there and
you will not be sliding at the same
speed as you would thinking that you're
going to be attracted by Alpha Centauri
at the same rate you are here no you
won't once you enter the linear regime
you're the going very very slowly
forever why slowly though well because
uh you don't have to keep your picture
you need that you need that uh see
that's but doesn't the brisbee hold you
back
well it's a long story I you got to look
at my video I just don't want to get
into it because it's uh you need a long
explanation for that okay but my point
here is there's a linear regime between
two balls okay you have two balls right
and imagine they're connected okay right
there let's see yeah like so okay
okay yeah yeah okay so they're connected
okay and so what happens if you're
trying to get out of here here in close
to the ball you're gonna have this
bird's Peak and in the within the bird
speak you have Newton's gravitational
equation but when you get to the you
know to the long linear regime uh at
that point you travel slowly because
there is no attraction from Alpha
Centauri or from the Sun for that matter
you sure you don't want to get into it
no it's too much that's uh it's it's too
late I've got a video look at Pioneer
anomaly and uh well
otherwise we're going to spend all night
here with this one
okay so here's uh Here's the final issue
um China edging out Russia on sanctions
to redraw Kazakhstan trade you have all
these countries they're the stands uh
Kazakhstan Kyrgyzstan who's Pakistan and
so on and people say are these countries
are they are these countries that belong
here on Earth and here's here's the map
okay so that you can put in the right uh
context and you can see uh put the uh
populations in each one and that's that
region between Russia and China Russia
has a hundred million more people in
Ukraine but China has 10 times more
people than Russia and what's happening
now is those
um countries that used to be part of the
Soviet Union in other words they were
governed from Moscow aren't no longer
are and what happens is Russia still
maintained quite a bit of Commerce with
them but China is now Muslim Russia's
side and taking over uh the country
that's not involved there very much is
the United States or Europe for that
matter you know none of those have much
influence in that region and China is
now kind of muscling Russia aside uh
keep that in mind because this war in
Ukraine has got uh Russia busy uh with
what's going on over there on the on its
eastern border and here you have China
Mustang in in their own uh territory
trying to conquer you know some of these
countries through Commerce and there you
can see the uh
uh you know how China has is uh
having some inroads into those countries
uh the black is the um China and orange
one is Russia you can see how slowly and
slowly the Chinese are Muslim the
Russians aside so that's going to have
an impact in the next few years okay
keep that in mind okay so I thought I'd
mention that as well
okay uh let's move on to the subject
matter today oh okay yeah we get
there subject yeah subject what is this
I don't know what the subject is what is
the subject subject is is there such a
thing as the fourth dimension
dude
[Music]
uh well that was a twilight zone is this
the same thing four dimensional I mean
can you even imagine the fourth
dimension yeah sure you can imagine the
Twilights well it depends how many beers
you had you know I mean no I'm in the
Twilight Zone you can imagine they show
it to you it's a video okay so what
dimension no no well we're gonna start
this uh segment with a fellow who
uh asked a question or made a comment
okay so we'll go with this comment first
here it is
first fell says check 3D toilet paper
sheet remove one dimension okay what
if it's thickness it uh it does not turn
into 2D or a 1D it turns into Zero D
okay so you got zero D in 3D in the real
world so he's saying look you take
toilet paper right it's 3D right you
remove one of the dimensions whichever
one you want uh let's you and he says
remove thickness for example okay he
said you don't end up with 2D the other
two Dimensions you end up with zero D
because there's nothing there anymore
just by removing one dimension
no kid what
so 3D minus 1D is not 2D 3D minus one D
is zero D he says
now he it took him a long time I think
uh he deserves a Nobel Prize okay that's
what I think okay 3D minus one D that's
new math
3D minus one D is equal to zero D not to
two D okay
same fellow he says the following he
kind of laughs a little bit he says
number of numbers referring to the
definition of the dimension okay and he
grins okay yeah uh if you look up the
word Dimension okay at least uh
Wikipedia can look up anywhere really
the minimum number of coordinates that's
the definition uh for what for Dimension
no no but the minimum number of
coordinates for no no just the minimum
number coordinate blah blah blah
yeah it doesn't matter what comes after
that uh coordinate that's the important
part isn't it no no this is the
important part because they're defining
what it is says number of coordinates so
what is a coordinate it's a number so we
have the number of numbers so he's
laughing at himself he doesn't realize
that those are the definitions that the
mathematicians work with yeah in
mathematics a dimension is a number line
yeah that's number so it is the number
of numbers that's what a coordinate uh
what a dimension is now does a line give
it a direction already no that's the
point the point is I discussed that task
n is is after eight yeah but it's not in
that direction but it's not see this is
the point uh that's not a direction
numbers have no direction I can put a
number that way
yeah but but that's why they put it on
the number line to give you the sense of
direction when numbers have no Direction
it makes no sense to put numbers in a
given Direction okay yeah that's the
issue because these numbers as well flip
them yeah or you can put them like I did
the other day I put them in different
orders yeah like a three over here or
four over here is are you going to hold
it against me I mean there's no
direction to numbers and the point here
is that the dimensions of math are not
the same as the dimensions of physics
which aren't length width and height so
when they talk about Dimensions they're
not talking about length width and
height at least not always this is more
or less like the dichotomy between
weight and mass
wait a masses sometimes weight and
sometimes it ain't sometimes it's
quantity of matter and sometimes it's
how it presses up against the scale yeah
and when they want to use one notion
they use that one when they use the
other one they use the other one nobody
here
notices the difference because they
always use the word mass and this is
something similar here they say look uh
a dimension and you say well you're
talking about length with our height no
I'm talking about all those numbers on
the line so you're not talking about
dimensions of physique but they use it
in both senses they say well it's this
and it's also this so they cover all the
bases and they think they're doing
physics mathematical physics because
they're putting numbers underneath
length or width or I mean sometimes they
also give they also say temperature is a
number is a dimension yeah and and
the temperature is a dimension then we
got a problem because I mean it's the
same problem it's time being a dimension
where it's like right people say we live
in a 4D universe but it's like well
they're accounting temperature then it
negatively 5D are you counting uh the
imaginary numbers and they came up with
and that's exactly how they do it they
say look it's a dimension of uh laughing
yeah because what is that what do you
mean three and four or five Dimensions
there's as many as you can come up with
and here it is and then the word just
becomes meaningless at that point and
here it is okay uh we started with a
universal movie and we're saying first
that we're gonna put number number nine
and Vector in the dynamic region and
dimension coordinate in the static
region what is static what is the
universal movie well the single frame
Omni represents static Concepts and if
you need at least two frames as all
those at the bottom or more you know uh
you're gonna you're gonna have Dynamic
Concepts why because as you can see the
word number right there at the bottom is
the verb to count that's what it means
that's what the word number stands for
number is the verb to count numeral is
the symbol you use to represent counting
okay and a number line and Vector are
both Dynamic Concepts vectors a dynamic
concept because it's displacement okay
Vector is what uh magnitude and
direction direction away what do you
mean numbers go in a given Direction
magnitude's going a different direction
no what it is is that they say look
here's a we put an arrow to B and
something moved from A to B but what
they want to do is put some numbers
there so they can say at what speed or
what rate or whatever a went to b or how
much distance it covered or whatever so
a vector represents motion always that's
why you say magnitude and Direction but
see the word direction doesn't belong in
math you can't add directions you can't
subtract Direction multiplying direction
is a word that belongs in physics
exclusively not in math at all okay and
this is where the problem is they say
magnitude and Direction the vector
belongs to math now Vector is one thing
which it belongs to physics and what I
was in math is the number line which has
nothing at all to do with Direction
number lines don't have directions
except in math we have our first
question how many dimensions does the
Flat Earth have
good questions the same question we we
addressed some time back yeah uh it's
not that it's like when I asked him how
flat is flat is flat and so if it's
completely flat it's like this guy says
you subtracted
you ended up with zero Dimensions okay
that's but uh you know how flat is flat
uh
uh and and they always show it as a
pancake not not as a flat flat so
instead of flatters it's a pancaker the
two inch and it's resting on Turtles you
know yeah Turtles
okay so uh here's the recap for that
okay we have numbers number lines and
vectors they are Dynamic Concepts
whereas dimensions and coordinates are
static Concepts in math Dimension
coordinates equal number lines okay
that's what they mean when they say
coordinate or Dimension they're talking
about number lines number line lacks
Direction Number Nine has no reason to
have any direction whatsoever you don't
put numbers in a given order except you
know to uh to organize it for someone
but to actually think that numbers have
direction is what's irrational well I
think the irrational part is already the
term number line yeah the number line
line the word line should not be in
there okay in fact the word line does
not belong in math either because line
and point assuming you it's a DOT right
they belong to physics those are objects
you know well it depends on what line
we're talking well but I'm using this
what I'm saying conceptual one then yeah
I guess you could put a floating number
line there
[Music]
represent objects do not belong in math
at all you can't add or subtract tables
yeah table minus table you can add you
can subtract one minus one but not table
minus table you cannot subtract objects
or three from a table or whatever you
know wood
okay and so number nine lacks Direction
okay therefore infinite you know uh the
number line is infinite yeah you can
count forever that's what infinite means
really in math uh number lines you can
put like you were saying a minute ago
that you have all these number lines and
if a number line is you know temperature
or time you can put a million of them
you know you can have the dimension of
intelligence or whatever you know
whatever you want in math 4D is uh equal
to number lines that's what they say
when they say something is four
dimensional they're saying it's for
number lined okay that's what they mean
so when you see the Tesseract there you
know Tesseract is not four dimensional
they they're saying it's for number line
okay that's what it's all about but what
about temperature well the same thing
it's number line but it's missing there
that's right yeah
well yeah I could what about color
Dimensions
no no the reason I put only that there
that number line right because
the Tesseract is allegedly an object
that has length width and height that is
growing that is expanding yeah that's
that's what a tesseract is supposed to
be so what is it's expanding through the
dimension of time they say that's it
sounds so complicated yeah see so it's
all what they're talking about is number
lines they're saying we're going to use
these numbers in our calculations and
we're going to call that result of
Tesseract and they sneak it in there
saying it's got length width and height
it's a cube right and you say okay I
understand that it's a few good but
they're but what they're really
representing is each one of those length
width and height they're represent
they're replacing them with number lines
that have Direction and then they have
this thing that has Direction already
and now they're going to expand this
moving object this this cube right
they're going to expand it through time
which is that corner uh number line
right and that's how you build the test
right so this is a moving on this is not
an object this is an object that is
expanding in this moving through through
time I guess you know I don't know this
is how they handle it in math okay but
it has nothing to do with physique this
is not a physical object okay
uh and again uh you can see the math
number lines have nothing to do with the
dimensions uh of physics they also have
nothing to do with the coordinates or
vectors of physics okay so what do we
have we have uh length and height are
the dimensions physics uh coordinates uh
are a way of locating an object with
respect to other three reference points
which are at 90 degrees to each other
perpendicular to each other orthogonal
and so what you have is Altitude
um latitude and um what's the other way
uh longitude latitude and altitude and
then vectors are depth breadth and
elevation because you're having motion
depth going deep right
um breath you know sideways motion and
elevation upwards motion okay so uh
those are the vectors that belong
exclusively to physics in math none of
those have any relevance what they look
at in math are number lines and that's
where people get confused because are we
talking about dimensions are we talking
about number lines that's what you got
to keep in mind
and here we have um
uh some questions for you okay for you
to ponder today okay we have these
questions is there such a thing as the
4D for the mention is there any object
that is four dimensional can you imagine
any object that is 4D if so please draw
it and we'd like to see it normally you
can draw it you can only imagine it well
have it in my head
that's how I do that yeah put your head
give us a piece of your brain your mind
okay is there an entity that is 10
dimensional as String Theory alleges
okay dimensional I can come up with way
more than that depends on how many beers
no whiskey it's the top of my head I can
already come over here and there you see
my 16-dimensional universe okay is that
possible uh is that is that what you're
staring at there is that a 16
dimensional universe or is it just a
bunch of lines on a flat surface missing
temperature uh color well you put
anything you want in those you like you
say you call it anything you want
yeah but here it is uh here we have the
people in mathematical physics they're
gonna put you straight they're going to
tell you exactly
how they visualize Dimensions okay this
is what this is about okay can you
visualize can you see are there such
things as 4D and upwards and here we
have our first uh witness this is what
he's going to tell us this is Mr Stephen
Hawking he says it is often helpful to
think of the fourth coordinates look at
look at this language okay core
coordinates of an event as specifying
its position in a four
dimensional space coordinates in
dimensional these mixing coordinates
with his Dimensions there called space
time it is impossible to imagine a
four-dimensional space it's easy okay
nobody I mean if he's this is the guru
right I mean if he's telling you how it
is you get accepted you know on the
basis of authority so he's saying you
cannot imagine the 4D okay that's our
first witness okay now we have another
one here's a good old irony okay and
this comes out of the Wikipedia and what
does he say uh
so
give me a second here get it back in
there
okay so it says in everyday life there
are three familiar Dimensions 3D of
space wait uh hate height width and
length Einstein's general theory of
relativity treats time as a dimension on
par with the three spatial Dimension I
like that spatial Dimension yeah yeah
also known as dimensions
the spatial difference in general
relatively space and time are not
modeled as separate entities but are
instead unified to a four dimensional so
they're treating time as a dimension
right so yeah you're right why do they
say 3D when it's 4D right they're all
the same in fact
um uh Hawking tells us there's no
difference between the time Dimension
and the space Dimension but then why
would he make a difference for the
temperature dimension
says in this framework the phenomenon of
gravity is viewed as a consequence of
the geometry of space-time but then on
the right hand side there you see all
the strings here is okay and they say
something different they say in spite of
the fact that the universe is well
described by 4D space-time there exists
scenarios in which there could actually
be more than 40 uh than the four
dimensions of space-time which have
nonetheless managed to escape detection
so we cannot detect these Dimensions
okay that's what these people say these
are the string theorists okay and
they're trying to unify a Quantum with
uh relativity that's what their business
is that's what their job is here they
are again so string theories require
extra dimensions of space time so they
can't just live with general relativity
at its four lousy Dimensions they need
to have a lot more okay we're just
talking about locating something right
well let's find out let's find out what
these people tell us says for their
mathematical consistency in basonic
string theory space time is 26
dimensional while in super strength
Theory it is 10 dimensional and in M
Theory it is 11 Dimensions did you ever
look up what these dimensions are
exactly well I wish they would name them
so we knew what they don't name them no
no of course not they just say because
they're talking about number lines
they're not dealing with Dimensions at
all but they call them dimensions and
that's what confuses people you know
they're talking about number lines in
order to describe real physical
phenomena using string theory one must
therefore imagine scenarios in which
these extra Dimensions would not be
observed in experiments
what so you can't detect them through an
experiments but they're out there kind
of fishy it's like saying we know
they're there we're the mathematicians
you got to believe us but we can't find
them even through experiments well I
mean for for fairness we say the same
thing with the ropes right yeah but yeah
but see this is the issue we're not
asking people to believe we're saying
look we're going to make an assumption
that there are ropes out there right
this is not what these people are saying
they're saying we proved it we know we
we certified and why can't we see them
well it's called
compactification that's why we can't see
them or detect them with experiments is
one way of modifying the number of
dimensions in a physical theory in
compactification some of the extra
dimensions are assumed to close up on
themselves to form circles we have
current Dimensions here right
the hose listen to this this is the
example they give if the hose is viewed
from a different from a sufficient
distance it appears to have only one
dimension its length uh-huh if you can
see it from anywhere it's got at least
two Dimensions but they say it's got
only one dimension and that's length
okay we'll accept that for the moment
however as one approaches the hose one
discovers that it contains a second
dimension its circumference so
circumference is now a 2d Dimension a
two-dimensional thing right thus an ant
crawling on the surface of the hose
would move in two dimensions
so they're talking about moving in two
Dimensions I thought I thought motion
had to do with vectors but here they're
saying so dimensions and this is the
punch line here okay here's These Fine
gentlemen they say in physics string
theory is a theoretical framework in
which the point-like particles of
particle physics are replaced by a
one-dimensional objects called strings
so the string is one-dimensional and the
question is what dimension does it have
length width or height whatever yeah
numbers that's what they're talking
about okay they're not talking about
Dimensions at all okay then they call
them strings okay and straight Theory
describes how these strings propagate
through space so we have one dimensional
strings which no one can imagine we
cannot imagine a zero or a one dimension
or a four-dimensional straight saying
they're not they're not skinny they're
they are literally
one dimension yeah because they're
talking about number lines they're not
talking about Dimensions so they say no
we have all these we don't need length
of the night we don't even need to
imagine it just right right we just care
about the number line right forget the
why does but they're giving a dimension
to the number line yeah but let's listen
hold on can I just really quick yeah
yeah this string that they're talking
about has one dimension right or they
say like that but aren't they just
saying that they're only using one
number line because that's all they need
exactly so why
call it a string why call it a dimension
why because all these things because the
word string yeah immediately takes it
into physics yeah that's the body so
it's misleading the same string because
people imagine you know this is a string
you know people say okay I understand
what a string is here it is in Black
right I I know what a string is it looks
something like that right so people say
okay I know what string is what you're
staring at is not one-dimensional
because otherwise you couldn't see it
okay it's at least two dimensional right
at least from your point of view because
you have length and
um I'm sorry you have width and height
there from your Vantage Point okay you
have width which is sideways right and
height which is the thickness of the
string so you have two Dimensions they
call this one dimensional that's well
they don't call that one well they call
it because it's the other way around
they take a number line and call that a
string which is what people think is but
they tell you that's one dimensional
well it is it's a one but what they're
saying is we have one number line yeah
the one dimensional one number line and
we're going to call that a string no I
don't call it a string string makes it
sound too they're quite a dimension yeah
I don't call it a dimension either I
mean this is they call it a dimension
when they're it's it's not even one day
in physical and dimension makes it sound
real but look at the look at the example
they give you a hose and they say you
look at the hose from far away and it's
1D no it's 2D from anywhere in the world
that you can see if you can see it from
the other side of the universe it's
still too deep at least at least if not
3D but for sure 2D it's not 1D but they
say what you're staring at is what is
One D and that's where they make the air
and then they say oh if it's 1D it's
only length and if it's length it's a
string so this is how they make the you
know transition real quick is there
anything in that it that exists
that isn't exactly three-dimensional
no okay 3D everything everything that
exists is exactly three exactly 2D does
not exist uh 2D you can think of it this
way yeah a square is the face of a cube
so you're staring at the square let's
say you just stare and you can't see the
rest of the cube behind it we say that's
a square that's a 2d object but that's
what you're seeing essentially what we
do is we're saying well we don't need
the third dimension so we're just going
to do without it because they do that in
programming also where they just
basically throw away the z-axis because
they're like okay for this object we
don't need it so just it's two
dimensional
only because we don't need the third one
and these guys took it a step further
they're like this is one dimensional
because we we don't need the the other
two yeah we don't need more so let's
just call it one number but but there's
no such thing as a one-dimensional or a
two right but it's just what how many
dimensions do we need for that yeah what
I'm worried about is what these people
are saying because they're saying that
this right that this is one dimension
because you're seeing it from far away
and say well that's just one dimension
no this is two-dimension if you can see
it it's at least 2D and they think that
a line you know in uh geometry they say
a line is 1D now a line is 2D and a
point is 2D
a number line is one dimensional even
the length because the line the line is
the demand you're not the numbers the
numbers are constant you know something
that is one-dimensional length no the
minds of these people
with with is one dimension yeah okay so
here we have uh these people are saying
that the hose is One D and you can see
it's at least 2D but they call it the 1D
hose they have the little ant crawling
around it and they say the ant is going
around in two Dimensions no no that's
not demand those are number lines that
they're talking about you know uh you
know the ant only lives in 3D World okay
so but these people call that two
dimensions and there you can see on the
bottom left an example of
compactification at large distances a
two-dimensional surface with one
circular Dimension looks one dimensional
now is that one dimensional or it looks
like two-dimensional still to me
it looks one dimensional look that's an
oxymoron looks one dimensional what do
you mean looks one dimensional if it's
one dimensional I can't look it can I
but this is the issue they they they
point to they point to a two-dimensional
object you're staring at it you drew it
you know on the board and they say
that's one D I'm gonna say it's my
skinny buddy next time you look
one-dimensional bro
you gotta eat something you look
wonderment okay so this is where the
strings look like what do they look like
one-dimensional things whatever they
look like what at least I would say
bubbles well no no because you're
supposed to see him uh as a just uh a
two-dimensional one-dimensional thingy
okay
is it is a two or one yeah
of course they're saying that these
wigglings are what creates so what
you're looking at is the particles and
they say a particle is really a
vibrating one-dimensional string but I
see that it's got two Dimensions
otherwise I wouldn't see it right if
it's one dimensional we wouldn't see it
at all right and so well and they have
it vibrating back and forth they say the
different vibrations are different
particles this is for dramatic and
yeah they're not they don't actually
look like that yeah but see they're
trying to they're trying to illustrate
something which is unillustrated it's
unimaginable let alone illustratable you
cannot imagine that dummy is like like
us but
I was a little Slaughter slow they gotta
show us the flashy lights okay let me
tell you what the story is you know in
the old days uh people believe that uh
you die and your soul goes to heaven
right what your soul goes to heaven
right okay yeah but this comes out no no
where are you going with this okay
you'll see where I'm right you'll see
where I'm going with this okay so here's
don't tell me the government lied about
that too
I want to go to heaven okay so here here
are the people going to heaven this is
the way it used to be okay normal stuff
I closed the gates yeah people would die
you know all over the Earth and they
would slowly you know seep into heaven
and today we have something different or
something similar really almost exactly
alike and it's uh uh this fall Brian Cox
you know and he says that all these
gravitons that produce gravity they go
to some unseen dimensions and that's
what it looks like I guess graviton's
going into this uh uh four-dimensional
world
okay and this is what uh Mr Cox says he
says look uh the reason gravitons
disappear is that they vanish into a
place beyond our reality into some sort
of extra Dimension there can be extra
hidden unseen Dimensions it sounds
ridiculous and it is impossible to
picture but theoretically it is possible
that's what he said this is a so-called
physicist okay and it's also possible
that gravitons the particles of gravity
can spend most of their in their time in
those extra Dimensions okay so gravitons
of their time yes it's like they're
people yeah yeah they spend all their
time you know going to this uh
four-dimensional heaven
you know it used to be the souls that
went there now it's the graviton oh my
God so this these guys haven't invented
anything new they're just uh replacing
Souls with uh you know with uh gravitons
so the reason we don't see the gravitons
is they're they're in the other in
unseen undetectable Dimensions I got a
question
uh is the Rope one-dimensional no
absolutely not 3D everything that exists
is 3D Europa exists you could say
because it uh stands between two objects
and for that we have to Define exactly
what the word exists means so what an
object is it's even 3D as far as
Imagining the structure yeah well 3D I
mean that's what a rope is that's 3D and
we're not kidding anyway we're not
saying this is 1D or 2D this is 3D okay
and we're saying the Rope is 3D okay the
Rope is 3D it's just so thin so tiny
that we cannot see or detect it and it's
Untouchable unseeable and you say Bill
you're uh
you're introducing ghosts and goblins no
we're saying that is saying 1D as ghosts
we're saying that a rope is this this is
a rope and it's 3D and that's what we're
saying it is 3D no problem there okay
hopefully and you say well we can't
touch it and or see it then you're
introducing you know fantasy no no
because an object is not that which you
can see or touch an object is that which
has shape and hopefully this has shape
so we we met the condition for an object
now for existence we need to have it
location in the universe with respect to
the rest of the matter in the universe
and a rope does have that so yes the
Rope exists under that definition and
that's just to produce the hypothesis a
hypothesis is something you take at face
value in order to understand the theory
found it upon it as far as the Cox guy
right yeah it kept you really yeah well
yeah because
it's just amazing to me how physicists
are still so full of physical don't call
them physics please whatever you want to
call them math magicians yeah that's
better even they who dedicate their
lives to science or at least try to are
so filled with like poetry metaphor a
Superstition it's no wonder that that
there's still religion around well
people out there they want real answers
they want to know why this pencil falls
to the floor that's all we need to
answer they haven't been able to answer
the answer they haven't been able to
answer that in ten thousand years that's
weird and how difficult can this be you
know here we have I mean it's difficult
oh it is it is no the only reason it's
difficult you cannot see the mediators
and that's why we're saying the
mediators are the ropes it's easy to you
because you already got the if you know
the joke obviously it's easy until you
know it it's hard yeah anyways here's
the run down the conclusions for today
there you have it uh bath Fizz you know
mathematics has three branches general
relativity quantum mechanics and string
theory relativists confess that they
can't even imagine the 40 let alone see
it okay so that's out of the way I can
imagine a lot of 40s okay well but
they're talking about length width and
height and time and they're thinking
about the hypersphere or the hypercube
or and they say you cannot imagine okay
great so that rules the 4D out but then
we have quantum mechanics that doesn't
deal with Dimensions at all right and
then string theory proposes 10 11 and 26
Dimensions you take your pick okay
whichever Theory you subscribe to
strength here is admit that they can't
see these Dimensions right string
dimensions are curled up and compacted
okay so they're curled up into little
kurdy cues and that's why you can't see
them and mathematicians allege that uh
Quantum mechanic gravitons hide in
unseen undetectable dimensions that's
another way that they use the word
dimension in fact is used far more often
in fiction and movies and such Dimension
what it really means in like just day to
day it doesn't really mean like within
height what it means is an alternate
reality yeah yeah I guess that's how
they use the word there where they say
that graviton is in another dimension
they're not even talking about links
with high temperature or time they're
just saying it's in a different reality
so that's extra confusing when they use
the word Dimension and there's something
why do they use the dimension in both
terms when we're supposed to be doing
science here like pick one they can't be
both that's one issue the other issue is
that you notice that because they cannot
answer any question they cannot answer
gravity specifically they put all these
Dimensions beyond your grasp or be
beyond your understanding they say well
we don't understand it it's out there
all the gravitons go to this Heaven that
we can't see this 4D Heaven you know and
so they're not even trying they put it
beyond your reach so you say oh that's
so awesome oh they know so much they're
so wise yeah because they put it be on
your reach you're understanding you're
in they put it beyond your imagination
thank you that's this for these guys
because man we're too dumb to understand
this 26 dimension thing
okay folks let's move on to some of the
um questions the comments people made
one fellow made this comment they're not
gonna make fun of them aren't you no no
never okay uh here we have this phone he
says take a big round ball of wood and
imagine it's space of the uh in other
words that the spaces of the known
universe it's as big as the universe
right now stream physical presence
through it by making holes in Caverns
okay so he's gonna strings holes through
it he's going to straighten yeah like
you know poke through it right okay and
he says he's gonna poke physical
presence with this okay yeah that would
represents space I thought it
represented his brain okay and the
spaces represent presence okay I don't
know what presence is but let's continue
both volumes can be calculated the
difference is that one has density and
the other doesn't volume has shape what
is he talking about
what uh bartender I'd like to have
whatever he had what no I wish I knew I
wish I knew enough what is poor presence
is he talking about like Consciousness I
don't know like physical present I don't
know or
he must have seen a ghost I don't move
the curtain
here we have someone even more
intelligent he says
he says so a black hole is basically
thick bunch of ropes
no um it's not a thick bunch of ropes uh
here we say there is no such thing as a
black hole so we say black hole is
nonsense
yeah you do explain the same uh let's
say what
because they use black holes to explain
the weird uh uh matter going through uh
uh I want to say Singularity but Point
well not let's show how how the idea how
this notion
to explain certain things I'll go
through that little things give me a
second here I'll go through it so this
is this is cygnus X1 this was the first
black hole supposedly detected by humans
first it was
um it's important to understand that the
notion of black hole came out of
mathematics okay we have sourcefield and
he was the first guy uh German guy who
came up with a notion and it was uh
followed through by Chandra secker and
then eventually by Stephen Hawking and
um Penrose Roger Penrose okay so these
people are the ones are the people who
uh really introduce black holes into the
uh general population and this was our
first detection okay of the black hole
cygnus X1 here it is they saw this star
okay in this constellation and this star
was moving in circles quite rapidly
around nothing
so they try to answer why is this
happening the astronomers right and they
say oh we know it's a black hole which
is was uh invented by uh Schwartz Hill
in fact uh maybe you can even go back in
time find a British guy who already had
come up with this notion of a uh star so
big that would collapse to a point so
they said there's a little point there
very massive point in the center of that
circumference in in the center of that
orbit of that star that we cannot see so
what did they do they put it in there by
hand
okay and so they put the black hole in
there and they say see this is why that
star goes around because there's a black
hole somewhere in there that's turning
it around we can't see the black hole
because it's black right no light can
come out of it and so This Is How They
proved that this star was actually you
know
um going around a black hole okay so
this is how it all began in the uh a few
decades ago really coming through four
or five decades I think this was in the
70s okay so this was our first detection
of a black hole they saw a star moving
around a center of gravity you know in a
circle well it's the first thing you
think well yeah if if there's something
there but uh yeah are we gonna put an
angel there if I put an angel say well
that's baloney Angels don't exist but
you accept that a black hole exists
which is what Zero Dimensional okay
let's make sure we understand that a
black hole has no matter whatsoever what
is mass it's the quantity of matter
is crushed out of existence in a black
hole black hole is zero D no size no
nothing it's the definition of nothing
and you're saying that a star goes
around nothing
that's what they're saying but they're
saying it goes around Mass not around
nothing it goes around heavy nothing and
so here it is let's listen to Mr Stephen
hawkingham chandraseker calculated that
a cold star of more than about one and a
half times the mass of the Sun would not
be able to support itself against its
own gravity would it collapse to
infinite density infinite density or
meaning Zero D really that's what they
mean it approaches zero but they always
say it's infinitesimal meaning it
approaches never he gets there but it
does because it crushes all matter out
of existence Eddington was shocked by
that implication Eddington was Sandra
secker's boss at the time and he refused
to believe Chandra secker's result
Eddington thought it was simply not
possible that a star could collapse to a
point Zero Dimensional Point remember
points are Zero D
Einstein himself wrote a paper what what
did Einstein say in which he claimed
that stars would not shrink to zero size
now what is zero size zero sizes nothing
it's space it's vacuum that's what zero
size is that's what a black hole is zero
size there's nothing there all matter
crushed out of existence
uh masses the quantity of matter there
is no matter because it's been crushed
out of existence it shouldn't have any
Mass either
but it can't be because the definition
of mass is a quantity of matter yeah but
so we got a circular argument
the mass is quantity of matter
yeah so well that's one definition once
the matter is is destroyed then the
definition becomes quantity of
was given the Nobel Prize for his
calculation that a star collapses to
zero size nothing genius no no uh
Dimensions no nothing genius and they
call that a black hole a nothing okay so
that's the starting point that's what
you should understand first okay okay so
how do we explain black holes this is a
black hole according to uh rope model
okay here we have we start with this we
see a Charged particle as it's called
we'll call it a charts ball means it's
got uh it's uh it's it's it has some
electricity in it again so it's got its
charge and we have a magnetic field
whatever a magnetic field is raining
down upon it and what it will do you can
reproduce this in the lab it will move a
particle this particle in circles around
itself okay like that like you see there
now is there a black hole in the middle
of that orbit the answer is no well can
I stop you real quick yeah so you're
saying gravity isn't the only thing that
would make a planet go in circles
exactly magnetism could do that as well
correct they completely discounted
magnetism right so you can see a
magnetic field does make a charge part
article move around in circles this has
been known for a long time since the
19th century this is not nothing new
that I'm presenting here okay I think
one of the majors didn't think about it
or they're like no no because there's no
magnetic field big enough the only thing
a mathematician considers mass and
gravity they'd never talk about
electricity is a thing they know that a
galaxy has magnetism in fact that's the
next point I want to show here's a
Galaxy okay yeah okay I believe this is
more or less what a Galaxy looks like
and it's really kind of fast here you
know Galaxy moves very very very slowly
okay and here's a Galaxy that is moving
a charged object such as a star around
in circles okay we have the magnetic
field of the Galaxy and it's raining
down on a poor little star that for some
reason is in a region where the magnetic
field is strong and it moves it around
in circles without there being in a
black hole in the center of that orbit
you do not need a black hole because
there is no such thing as a black hole
that mathematicians have been looking
for they're only looking at mass and
this is not a mass related phenomenon
this is a phenomena related exclusively
to the magnetic field of the Galaxy okay
and so it moves a charged object such as
all stars are all stars have a magnetic
field and so it's going to affect the
galactic magnetic field is going to move
the magnetic object this magnetic object
this little charged particle it's going
to move it around in circles without
there being any black hole whatsoever
you do not need a black hole uh to
explain this phenomenon known as a black
hole which according to their own
definitions and calculations is Zero
Dimensional
life is crazy so we have a totally
different explanation for what a black
hole is there's no such Monster Zero
Dimensional infinite density infinite
Mass
no such monster it's okay crazy how much
weird thing weird motions are going on
all at the same time
but you think that they'd have some I
guess that's what sucks when when
so-called scientists kind of boil it
down to not only things that don't make
sense but things that even they don't
understand but also things that because
when something can't be understood then
it takes all the fun out of it yeah and
so that's why everyone gets out of the
whole discussion but you know with the
punchline with the corollary to that is
is that uh Hollywood doesn't make uh
fantasy movies anymore they call them
documentaries because they get the
information from the mathematician and
yeah and they say look uh we're not
we're not cheating how many dimensions
223 hell yeah that makes us any more
mysterious they'll eat that up
anything there today uh is every atom a
universe
well I mean it's uh you can that's
poetic that's good but not literal yeah
I mean Universe uh is space and matter
that's what uh Universe the word
Universe stands for it's a concept
there's no so physical object called
Universe it includes space which is a
concept nothing which serves as a
backdrop to the matter which is
interconnected all the atoms in the
universe are physically connected to
each other I think I know how you'll
answer this one but I want to ask it
anyway could a Galaxy be said to be
alive
no because living alive means that it
can move in a given Direction Against
Gravity
but see what I like about that answer
what I love about that answer what I
love about that answer which you don't
hear very often and YouTube discussions
in fact I was listening to one the other
day like two days ago that drove me
crazy because they don't do what you did
well you just did implicitly you had a
definition in your head and you just
followed the definition but you know
many people don't do that you follow the
definition
essentially what you said is well
according to the definition I gave it
would not be one by definition because
the definition I gave for alive the word
you use is goes against gravity and it
doesn't so it doesn't just follow your
definition well when other people well
depends on what you mean by a lot yeah
no if you don't like my definitions no
problem you you have the option of
redefining the word and defense
I guess the best way to clarify that is
it's always a yes or no depends on what
you mean by alive yeah but then then
again all you have to do is Define life
and we'll know we'll be on the same page
there's no babies yeah and hopefully you
don't say it's what reproduces and what
grows and none of that because not
everything my grandmother didn't
reproduce at the age of 80 you know so I
don't think she was alive
okay anything else out there a lot of
questions I don't get but okay see we
get a lot of them are also um rhetorical
so it's hard to separate those yeah
[Laughter]
that's that's it if I don't get them you
can get them I guess afterwards okay
folks we'll go out a day and we'll